okay key in these forms is
being able to range to measure
this isn't free sparring where
you're going to move however you need to
move this isn't it
this is one take one measurement
and that's all you get so as we go here
and i go forward
my he starts to come i'm not going to
take that foot
out i'm not going to use that foot to
measure
i've hidden it in that movement there
so he goes to cut i'm not going to go
one and then i get my angle
[Music]
okay don't don't don't come too close
you don't want to
tempt the guy you have to put me in
neutral
like i don't want to come in i don't
want to go out you get it
so you often go into saigon in your hair
i'm gonna tap okay
so there you go
as he goes this cut again
don't bring it at an angle
i'm not moving his sword out of the way
i'm displacing his sword i'm coming
straight down
two objects can't occupy the same space
boom secondly
when i come down they'll pull this back
into you
yes you can push down here but that's
not the tactic
the tactic is to get weight on the tip
thirdly with those two things
i don't just hit his weapon
it has to go into his center
so yes you're going to cut down
yes you're going to do this but there is
a pressure
into his center that's what atoshi is
all right let's look at the angle
deviation again
so he we go in
and he comes in all right so my angle of
deviation
is not going to be through a double
weighted
external movement so i'm not here
and i stay on the line of attack
until i get outside this range if i do
that
i'm going to be out of range
so when when i'm here like this
that weight shift is moving me to the
right
this weight shift is moving me straight
back
when i go here or i go like this and
then like that
either one is incorrect it's not it's
not
in inconsistent with how you always move
i have to always go to a yawn face and
then i hit the rotation
a yawn phase and then the rotation
so it's no different here when i step
here
i go to the young phase of this foot and
now
i'm weighted on a single ground vector
not in between and moving
so when i wait on this single vector i
have
began moving off the line of attack
it is it's no different than if i went
like this i'm here and i move to this
side
now that's it that i want to stay as
close to this vertical plane as possible
i don't want my spine to keep traversing
backwards
and now goes around boom
he's here so i'm going to move my spine
backwards by keeping my line of gravity
between my two feet and i'll be out of
range
and now i'm going to establish that
point you can see
that range does not change oh
so as i'm here let's film from here
i want you to keep an eye on my spine
and how much it traverses
so double weighted stepping back
single weighted turning
we want the second one
you're late the second i'm walking to
you you're already
ready okay
okay everything has to aim up
down down the center so you can see if i
stay
here this cut is going to be off my
center but that's the angle
down the center but once i
turn you see i move myself under that
and then once my foot turns and my hips
change location
the tiny little bit that i'm off i will
be on
so i'm down his center and my sword
is straight down my nose do you see down
my nose
down my spine see it's not over here off
side of my head you see
down my nose down my spine
not off go back
boom not over here that's not down his
center
this foot went too far
stay still down
his center there's his spine right down
his center
okay so let let's look at this again
he's going to push on my shoulder
and i'm here like this so we went over
this in the
in chiba's eight councilwood so when i
double pivot
i stayed on the line until
somewhere around here
[Music]
when i pivot correctly i'm already off
the line
this is just a re-uh
a re-vectoring for attack it's not my
deviation
the deviation already happened here this
is a re-vectoring for the attack
on the other one i still deviate he's
still deviating
until here then i'm off
so as i do this if you look at my hips
my hips are doing a circle that's my
deviation
like a count countless other arts that
do circles
so my hips are going to rotate i'm going
to put this plane here now
so when i shift my weight
i rotate my hips will change
places the right hip is now in front
i don't want my hips even and then i
step back with my hips even
so over here
when i when i do the cut now that means
that i'm not going to have square hips
and square shoulders i have a lean hip
and so i have a lead shoulder
if i don't have a lead hip and at least
shoulder
i didn't rotate in my angle of
deflection
do you see i didn't get out of the way
of the sword
change position here
not here okay let's go